il est décédé dans mes bras Théo à 7
mois il se réveille et il est pas bien
c'est ça il mangeait rien il faisait que
dormir et se réveiller en pleurant enfin
vraiment pas comme d'habitude donc on a
été une première fois aux urgences il
venait d'avoir une dent donc c'était
probablement ça ou qui pouvait quelque
chose le soir même il a eu du sang dans
les selles donc là on s'est dit bah
c'est très grave et retourner aux
urgences et on a attendu 5 heures pour
un bébé de 7 mois qui avait du sang dans
les selles en fait c'est le même interne
qui l'a vu le midi et le soir même il
était toujours là épuisé forcément nous
dit de rentrer chez nous en fait il
pensait à une gastro j'ai essayé de
régulièrement toutes les heures toutes
les deux heures tout ça d'aller le
réveiller lui donner un petit peu à
manger à boire ça ressortait tout
automatiquement la Nuit d'Après quand
moi je me suis levée pour aller
travailler je l'ai entendu pleurer et là
il allait pas bien du tout il était dans
les selles et il était tout tremblant on
a appelé le SAMU en même temps mais il
est décédé dans mes bras
on a essayé de le réanimer
par terre sur la route en attendant que
ça